[تصفيق]
صعبه صعبه صعبه
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفتي اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم الجيش الاسرائيلي
يقتلوا تسعه فلسطينيه ويصيبوا العشرات في
عمليه عسكريه كبيره داخل مدينه جنين
ومخيمها ويقول انه استهدف ثلاثه مطلوبين
من حركه الجهاد الاسلامي الفصائل توعدت
الاحتلال بالرد بينما طلبت الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه بتحرك دوليا عاجل مواجهه
قضائيه بين قاضي التحقيق في انفجار بيروت
والنائب العام اللبناني الذي احال طارق
البيطار الى هيئه التفتيش القضائيه القطار
قال للجزيره انه لن يمتثل لاي استدعاء
واكد استمراره في العمل بالقضيه في حين
حاول محتاجون اقتحام قصر العدل بالتزامني
مع اجتماعا لمجلس القضاء الاعلى بعد يومين
من اعلان الغرب ماده اوكرانيا بدبابه
قتاليه روسيا تساعده هجماتها وتستهدف
بعشرات الصواريخ والمسيرات مدن في ان
اوكرانيا الكريملين يؤكد ان الدبابات لن
تغير من طبيعه المعركه وتحدثت وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه عن تحضيرات قتاليه
الروسيه انطلاقا من القرد توتو ويوتيوب
يرضخاني لضغوط الحكومه الهنديه لحجب فيلم
عن تورط رئيس الوزراء الهندي في مجزره ضد
المسلمين ادت الى مقتل اكثر من 1000 شخص
عام 2002 تقرير لموقع بانتساب اكد ان
الشركتين نسقتان مع حكومه مودي لحزب
الفيلم الذي اعتبرته نيودله دعايه وفقالها